the Scarab chose you but it belongs to
me whatever you can imagine
I can create
August 18th welcome back everyone it's
Charlie DC just dropped a brand new Blue
Beetle trailer so we'll break it down
obviously there's a bunch of stuff
happening right now because the flash is
coming out so I'll explain how
everything is connected and what's going
to be happening going forward with the
reboot because James Gunn also just did
a big podcast recently sort of
clarifying where everything fits the
next couple of years especially with the
movies that are still coming out this
year like Blue Beetle The Flash movie
Aquaman 2. I'm also doing a giveaway for
tickets to The Flash movie all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
just post all your favorite moments from
the Blue Beetle trailers on the video I
do have a bunch of videos for The Flash
post credit scenes full breakdown Easter
eggs all that stuff coming out later
this week after it comes out in theaters
so don't worry I have a bunch of stuff
planned for that there's so much stuff
going on in that movie that we have to
talk about but we get a little new
footage of Jenny giving Jaime Reyes the
Blue Beetle Scarab at cord Industries
when he thinks he's going to get the job
in the big belly Burger case the funny
thing here there's so many Easter eggs
in this trailer if you watched any of
the arrowverse shows like Arrow throw
the flash Supergirl like any of the
arrowverse shows just in general big
belly Burger is a big DC location they
used it many times on all those series
you've only got one belly you don't have
to tell me that so why not treat it
right I'm starving there's a big belly
burger at big belly Burger we put our
best ingredients into our Burgers now
that's what I'm talking about so you can
put the best burgers into your belly so
this one has the triple stack that's for
you thank you
go ahead
you go to big belly Burger is always
going to taste like big belly Burger you
can be full of grease and salt
I thought those were the secret
ingredients hell no ma'am quite the
opposite even superheroes eat here for
the super quality now what now we go get
a big dummy Burger
it better be curly fries in there big
Billy burger now serving Star City and
Central City coming soon to National
City
[Music]
friends
kind of makes me want a burger right now
too they're in Palmyra City Florida
which is a reference to Ray Palmer's
version of the atom there was a Ryan
Choi version of the atom in the Justice
League Snyder cut but according to Zack
Snyder I don't think we were supposed to
see him become the Adam like where the
full suit Go full Adam until later
movies I don't think they'd ever planned
on doing an atom Solo movie but I think
the plan was for him to return in the
cyborg Solo movie that they had
originally wanted to do years and years
ago that would have featured him just
continuing to work at Star Labs because
that would have been a big location in
the movie they never really explained
what happened to the ray Palmer Adam in
the Snyder verse but they probably would
have just explained his story through
Ryan choi's storyline there's a much
bigger scene of him fighting car packs
later in the movie without his mask on
confirming that it won't just be his
Consciousness inside a robot like the
comics it'll be more traditional with
him working for Victoria cord in trying
to kill him using another suit built by
cord Industries to take the Scara back
by force but in the comics car pack
started out as a normal human who was a
villain to the original Blue Beetle way
back in the day Dan Garrett during his
many fights against Dan Garrett he
discovered a secret lab belonging to Ted
cord's Uncle more connections to the
second version of Blue Beetle the lab
contained an indestructible suit of
armor that you see in the trailer here
he couldn't get it to work and wound up
electrocuting himself killing himself
his mind got transferred into the robot
so he basically became this Immortal
robot with the mind of a human and
because he was Immortal he just
eventually lived on to become a villain
to the second version of Blue Beetle Ted
court so 50 50 on whether or not car
packs survived the end of the movie like
whether or not Blue Beetle winds up
killing him in the fight or he decides
to turn good and somehow dies after
trying to help Blue Beetle his villain
named car packs is also a reference to
the hard EXO skeletons that a lot of
animals particularly bugs beetles in
this case have like they're both wearing
suits even though the reach themselves
had nothing to do with car packs he's
like an earlier Golden Age villain that
then transitioned to the Silver age it
seems like what's happening with the
reach in the movie is it'll just be
light references to them like there'll
be a couple scenes where they allude to
what's happening with the reach in
general you start to see it broadcasting
signals more Cosmic looking scenes I
think they'll just reference what's
going on that in the history of the
reach and when they start digging into
the history of the Scarab like how Ted
Court originally found the Scarab what
happened with the Dan Garrett version
The Blue Beetle how he found the Scarab
the way they're talking about the movie
The Way James Gunn has been talking
about the DCU going forward it sounds
like there won't be a Blue Beetle sequel
movie even though this movie looks solid
it's supposed to be like a smaller movie
it seems like it'll be a lot of fun the
way that James Gunn and the other people
behind DC now are talking about the Blue
Beetle character especially some of the
trade magazines recently say that Blue
Beetle is probably going to cross over
in the Booster Gold HBO series that
they're going to be working on the next
couple of years but they didn't say when
that's coming out there's been a long
history of Blue Beetle and Booster Gold
crossovers in the comics and if you
watch Smallville episodes back in the
day there was a big Crossover with those
characters with the Jaime Reyes version
of Blue Beetle
you're an Excel right
[Music]
they haven't said who's going to be
playing the Booster Gold of the new
James Gunn DCU but if James Gunn said
that a bunch of his Guardians of the
Galaxy actors like his Marvel actors
he's worked with before will probably
transition into DC roles at some point
in the future I think that Chris Pratt
would actually play a solid Booster Gold
he'll also be continuing as the
Star-Lord character in like Avengers 5
Kane Dynasty like at the end of
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 it says the
legendary Star-Lord will return it was
meant to be a big joke about how he
called himself the legendary Star-Lord
in the first Guardians of the Galaxy
movie but nobody knew who he was so
because now James Gunn is taking over
DCU don't be surprised if you see a lot
of prominent Marvel actors showing up in
DC roles as different characters but
they also continue in other Marvel
movies so it'll be a little bit weird
but not that weird the other big
connection with stuff that James Gunn is
already working on is with The
Peacemaker character so Peacemaker and
Blue Beetle have a big Connection in the
comics he served as sort of a mentor to
the young Jaime Reyes for a while and
the funny thing is really early theory
that might not wind up doing this but I
do think it to be really really funny
just because Peacemaker is such a
ridiculous character in the comics they
use crisis on infinite versus big
Multiverse movie to sort of tie up a lot
of their continuity and clean things up
behind the scenes after that going
forward they explained that psycho
pirate was a character who remembered
everything that came before a crisis
before this big hard reboot in the DC
like the James Gunn era of DC films it
would be hilarious if they just make
that peacemaker's character and he's the
only person that remembers everything
from before the reboot because he came
from before the reboot in one of his big
character traits is that he's always
yelling about crazy conspiracy theories
so it just totally in character for him
to be yelling about a big DC reboot but
nobody believes him and he's the only
one that remembers and it's actually
true it actually happened Superman's an
alien he's got a poop fetish what [__]
out of here oh yeah where do you get
this nonsense
Google I'm telling you Superman used to
be completely different the Justice
League looked completely different
what's going on why doesn't anybody else
remember this James Gunn did confirm
that Peacemaker season 2 will start
immediately after Superman Legacy comes
out but that's not coming out till 2025
so it'll be a couple more years for
Peacemaker season two but do not be
surprised if you also see him crossing
over with the Blue Beetle character like
Blue Beetle showing up at some point
during Peacemaker season 2. this is him
actually talking about where the Blue
Beetle character sort of fits into the
DC continuity just in general and The
Flash movie as well the MCU and now the
DCU in film which really doesn't start I
mean the first DCU character for sure is
Blue Beetle in the First full DC move
DCU movie is Superman if there were Alex
Luther in this movie and there's a lot
of other villains so it may not be like
and you are the best Lex let's admit it
we know you're the best Lex come on
you're being funny I'm not being funny
you're definitely the best Lex really
definitely so what he's basically saying
there is that he consider Blue Beetle to
be the first real DCU character in The
Flash movie for instance even though it
sets up the big DC reboot with all the
Multiverse stuff that's happening in the
movie don't worry I'll talk about that
later this week because some of it does
get into spoilers he's not wrong either
Michael Rosenbaum is one of the best Lex
luthurs that they've ever had he doesn't
really consider The Flash movie or
Aquaman 2 to be true DCU movies once you
see The Flash movie you'll understand
what he means by that it is still very
much a Snyder verse movie with some ties
to what's happening with the reboot and
even though Jason Momoa said that he's
definitely coming back in the DC movies
it sounds like he will be a different
character right now it just seems like
Lobo like he's been talking about Lobo I
did a video about it a while ago too so
as we get more details about that of
course I'll do videos and we'll start
getting Aquaman 2 trailers later this
year so we'll be talking about it then
as well the way that James Gunn is
talking about it a lot of actors will
stay the same like Gal Gadot is still
going to continue to play Wonder Woman
even though she won't show up for a
while what they're going to do is for a
lot of those actors that will continue
as their care characters they'll just
retune their backstories a little bit to
fit with what's going on in the
backstory of the new DCU for example
Wonder Woman's backstory gonna change a
little bit because they're doing that
the mascara series which is kind of like
Game of Thrones with Wonder Woman
characters but set years before Wonder
Woman was born more than 5 000 years ago
so when Wonder Woman does show up in
present day after the events of that
series they'll have to retune her
backstory so that it makes sense with
what's already happened there's a bunch
of stuff coming up I got a bunch of
Flash videos planned so be sure to
enable alerts for my channel so you
don't miss that also Marvel secret
Invasion episodes are starting next week
so it is going to be crazy there'll be
so much stuff going on click here for my
brand new Superman and Justice League
Flash trailer video and click here for
the opening scenes from Marvel secret
Invasion episode one they posted the
full opening scene they're actually
pretty solid thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and I'll see
you guys in the next one
[Music]
thank you